for the past couple of months we've been
seeing some really strange leaks when it
comes to apple's mac lineup for the rest
of the year including the new redesigned
macbook air which might be more
disappointing than we all hoped for at
one point we were expecting a new
redesigned mac mini and a 13 inch m2
macbook pro at apple's march event but
that didn't happen because we got the
mac studio and the studio display then
we got some weird leaks from knightfi
mac telling us that the high-end mac
mini isn't even coming until next year
and that's exactly what ming chico said
last month claiming that the mac pro the
imac pro and the mac mini aren't coming
this year at all which he confirmed
after the march event and that right
there is a real shocker because all of
us were expecting the mac pro to come at
wwdc
because that's the last piece of the
puzzle to complete apple's two-year
transition to their own ships and even
worse he predicted that the new mac mini
in 2023 will likely remain the same form
factor design which would be a bit
embarrassing for apple but the biggest
bombshell of all that i was not
expecting was when ming chuko gave us
some updated predictions for the new
redesigned macbook air and trust me this
came as a complete shock he said that
mass production will begin as soon as
the end of the second quarter which is
june with an m1 ship no mini led display
an all new form factor design and more
color options and yes he did just say
the m1 chip which is exactly the same
chip that's already in the current
macbook air and when i first heard this
i completely dismissed it because it
didn't make any sense at all to me and
it just sounded unrealistic but now that
i'm really thinking about what's going
on over the past month as well as some
major leaks from mark german i think it
could actually make sense but before i
get into how mark german's old leaks and
a brand new report on sunday line up
with his new redesigned m1 macbook air
theory i want to get into some recent
developments that are starting to make
me lean towards this worst case scenario
for the macbook air as we all know the
tech industry has been facing supply
chain issues over the past year or so
and even apple has been impacted by them
but now i think things are getting much
worse especially over this past weekend
so let's begin it all started about a
month ago on march 9th with mainstreak
reporting that apple may not launch any
new mini led products this year due to
cost concerns which is extremely
disappointing making things even worse
because of supply chain issues ming
reported that regular iphone 14 models
coming this year will actually feature
the same old a15 chip that we already
have in the iphone 13 pro lineup and a
day after that report 95 mac confirmed
it with their own sources as well going
further ming said that there seems to be
no reason to be optimistic about the
2022 mobile phone market with many
companies including apple cutting orders
which implies that the entire mobile
phone industry is facing structural
challenges then on march 27th ming cut
his shipment estimate of the iphone se
by as much as 50
due to lowered demand but wait it gets
worse ming said that major chinese
android phone brands have cut orders by
about 20
compared to the original 2022 shipment
plan due to lower consumer confidence
and that's global markets not just china
and the scariest part of all is that he
mentioned that inventory levels of
certain rf chips have exceeded six to
nine months of supply but smartphone
demand is still going down due to low
consumer confidence about the economy
going further it looks like apple has
cut airpods 3 orders by 30 or more for
later this year because people aren't
willing to spend an extra 50 on airpods
3 which could mean that people's bank
accounts could be beginning to get tight
and now let's get into the absolute
worst possible scenario that started to
gain attention over the weekend which is
the massive lockdowns in china
apparently over 193 million residents
are in full or partial lockdown with
food shortages throughout even shanghai
china where subway passenger volumes
have slowed to a crawl being almost 100
shut down even worse air traffic going
through shanghai's two major airports
has dropped to levels lower than what
was seen at the height of the early 2020
lockdowns and as far as the supply chain
on the cargo ship side almost 500 ships
are waiting off east china's ports
because of the lockdowns and this is a
big deal because it's not just china
that's getting impacted about half of
german companies supply chains logistics
and warehouses are completely disrupted
or severely impacted by china's lockdown
situation and in terms of the united
states impact all of this is happening
on top of the already dire u.s supply
chain issues which peaked again in march
with logistics prices hitting a new high
and even tesla's shanghai factory could
be shut down until at least mid-may
according to new reports and because of
all of this going on ming chukwu just
reported that the lockdowns are starting
to affect iphone assembly and in the
best case scenario complete resumption
of production may not be possible until
late april or even early may and he
mentioned that the longer the lockdowns
persist the further effect on consumer
confidence which is already bad and this
would probably be detrimental to the
shipments of consumer electronics
including apple products in the second
half of 2022 and now when you take all
of this info into perspective it begins
to make sense why apple would decide to
drop the mini led plans for the macbook
air redesign as well as reuse the a15
chips in the new iphone 14 regular
models so what if the supply chain
issues are worse than we think and just
to give an ounce of evidence to that
idea apple has just confirmed to routers
that the iphone 13 is now also being
produced in india as the u.s tech giant
apple tries to reduce reliance on its
chinese supply chain so now with that
said i'm finally beginning to believe
ming when he says that the redesigned
macbook air is coming with the old m1
chip because the only reason this would
ever make sense is because the supply
chain issues are worse than we think and
it may be too expensive to put the m2
chip in the low end macbook air so if
this is all true apple's best option is
to do exactly what ming chaquel was
saying release a redesigned macbook air
with a bunch of new color options which
regular consumers are going to love and
buy regardless of if it still has the m1
chip because many consumers don't even
know or care that an m2 chip is supposed
to be coming soon the m1 is honestly
more than powerful enough for basic
users and going this route will allow
apple to save a lot of those new m2
chips in terms of the supply for their
more expensive products seeing as the
macbook air is apple's best-selling
laptop and it'll be much easier to give
it the m1 ship since they're already
mass producing it for so many products
including two of their ipads and this
finally brings me to some old and new
reports by mark german which didn't
really make sense until you consider
minchiko's prediction of a new
redesigned m1 macbook air many months
ago he predicted that we would be
getting both a new redesigned macbook
air and a new 13-inch macbook pro which
would be reusing the old design from the
m1 macbook pro and before we thought it
made absolutely zero sense because we
assumed that both of those macbooks
would be getting the new m2 chip so why
in the world would anybody pay more
money for the 13-inch macbook pro with
the same performance but with the older
design obviously people are gonna want
the new macbook air but now if the new
macbook air is truly getting the same m1
ship that we already have then the
people who really care about performance
would easily pay more money for the new
m2 13 inch macbook pro even if it has
the old design because the pros care
more about performance than the looks
and then with that said the lineup would
finally make a ton of sense again with
the redesigned m1 macbook air at the
bottom then the m2 old design 13-inch
macbook pro and then the new 14 and
16-inch high-end macbook pros and if you
think about it it makes so much sense
for this new m2 13-inch macbook pro to
use the old design because if apple gave
it the new design and the m2 chip it
would be stepping on the toes of the
higher end 14 inch macbook pro but with
the old design it no longer will be
doing that and now mark german's latest
power on report points to two new macs
coming around the middle of the year
potentially at wwdc and one of those is
likely the macbook air and if you think
about it if apple isn't ready to launch
the m2 chip until fall due to supply
issues giving the m1 chip to the macbook
air means that they could literally
launch it whenever they want to as soon
as the redesign is ready which could be
around the summer
and then as for that second mac that
mark german was talking about maybe they
can update one of the other macs with
the m1 pro chip perhaps the mac mini the
higher end to replace the intel model
that is currently still for sale on
apple's website so with that said to sum
up this entire video the recent supply
chain and economic issues are already
impacting apple which could lead to the
new redesigned macbook air sticking to
the same old m1 ship which is
disappointing because we were all
expecting the m2 now if you totally
disagree with my thoughts on this video
then let me know down in the comment
section below but if you learn something
new then go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and check out one of those two
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]